[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce Yves livre spécial
puisque ce sera une carte blanche que
nous donnons aux étudiants de Master 2
de littérature de recherche et création
littéraire pour être très précis de
l'Université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
et d'ailleurs je sais que le titre Yves
livre nous avait été suggéré par une des
enseignants de ce pasteur et qui
s'appelle Béatrice Guenin alors avec
nous Caroline Charder bonjour bonjour
Patrice alors on se connaît parce que
vous étiez déjà venu présenter des
livres ici et alors voilà c'est une
carte blanche qui pour thème on va le
dire tout de suite le patrimoine vous
allez nous expliquer dans un instant
Margot Nguyen Gogh mines ça va
oui très bien
je vous donnerai la parole vous
expliquerai pourquoi le patrimoine
d'accord
l'Union Lemarchand bonjour alors nous
aussi on se connaît vous étiez
présenter des livres l'année dernière et
puis Coralie Pelletier bonjour
vous allez chez quand et chacune nous
parlait d'un livre qui vous tient à cœur
comment s'est fait le choix de ses
livres
qui veut commencer oui bien sûr c'était
l'année dernière dans un séminaire que
donner madame barjoni autour des récits
d'enquête et j'ai eu un véritable coup
de coeur sur le livre sur lequel je
devais travailler ça a été vraiment une
belle découverte et un gros coup de
coeur tout simplement d'accord
Margot oui alors aussi dans le cadre
d'un séminaire c'était un ouvrage qui
était proposé éventuellement pour
constituer un dossier de recherche et
donc ouvrage que j'avais choisi et qui
m'avait beaucoup plu j'ai choisi parce
que je trouve que c'est une oeuvre très
intelligente et ça m'a fait beaucoup
rire d'accord Lilian personnellement
c'est un lecture personnelle qui m'avait
été conseillée par deux amis je suis
gâté Célia si jamais vous regardez
bonjour à Juliette
là saga qui était encore en cours à ce
moment-là et c'est ça a été un gros coup
de cœur
découvrir dans vos études soit voilà des
choix des choix de tout à fait personnel
le thème que vous avez choisi c'est le
patrimoine alors d'abord on peut définir
qu'est-ce que c'est le patrimoine on
connaît pas forcément le patrimoine le
patrimoine enfin après vous me coupez
vous le patrimoine c'est
comment reconstruire tout ce qui forme
le patrimoine enfin reconstruire ou
comment le préciser en insérant par
exemple pour la littérature des œuvres
écrites par des femmes ou étaient
délaissés dans l'histoire de la
littérature donc en fait chacun chacune
on a choisi un livre qui soit a été
écrit par une femme et où mais en scène
une héroïne voilà ou qui élèves aussi
des questions qui relèvent du patrimoine
c'est le seul garçon
mais vous partagez vous partagez
évidemment cette
conviction en effet c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que dans l'histoire de la
littérature pendant très longtemps c'est
en train de changer mais les femmes ont
été un peu laissées de côté quoi
exactement
pour être de publier et puis même à
l'école on apprend encore j'ai
l'impression d'être vieille quand je dis
ça mais on a tourné beaucoup encore à
mon époque de d'auteur et moins
d'autrices encore aujourd'hui je crois
beaucoup enfin une majorité d'oeuvre au
programme sont voilà écrites par des
hommes alors que en fait il me semble
que les femmes ont toujours écrit oui
alors il y a des œuvres comme il y a
quand même quelques quelques autrices ou
quelques romancières très célèbres même
dans l'histoire enfin bon mais c'est
vrai que
c'est assez peu assez peu et c'est bien
de vouloir rétablir la
justice au fond
qu'est-ce qu'on va commencer par parler
des livres on commence avec vous Margaux
oui
de parler de Morgane
exactement alors une œuvre non pas
écrite par une autrice mais non deux
garçons exactement donc Stéphane fer et
Simon quand ça va
mais alors on va dire qu'aujourd'hui
j'offre non pas pour la valorisation
d'une autrice mais pour une héroïne là
pour le
couple
alors oui à l'origine au Moyen-âge et en
fait il se trouve que c'est une héroïne
qui est mal aimée bah depuis cette
époque depuis des siècles alors pourquoi
bon alors on l'a qualifié à l'origine de
perfide de déloyale puis de sorcières
malveillante évidemment
mais alors qu'est-ce que Morgane a fait
pour pour avoir une tête postérité
et donc en fait
si on veut un peu comprendre ce qui
s'est passé peut-être pour pour
fabriquer un tel portrait et bien on
peut le lire donc
Morgane c'est un roman graphique
donc publié en 2016
aux éditions Delcourt voilà qui en fait
retrace
qui retrace en fait le récit narratif de
la Table Ronde du royaume de Bretagne
par le point de vue de Morgane donc la
demi-sœur d'Arthur et qui offre donc on
va dire une satyre grinçante de cet
univers fictionnelle là donc pour vous
pour vous lire un rapide résumé de
l'éditeur privé de son destin de Rennes
la demi-sœur du roi Arthur devient la
sulfureuse fait Morgane et se dresse
contre la tyrannie de la Table Ronde et
les manipulations de Merlin le fou
écœuré par le magicien qui joue avec sa
vie depuis sa plus tendre enfance
Morgane laisse libre cours à sa colère
et assouvit sa soif de pouvoir envers et
contre tous son ancien maître les hommes
leurs nouveaux dieux uniques et l'ordre
établi donc voilà c'est une femme qui se
révolte contre le pouvoir des hommes une
époque où voilà ce pouvoir est absolu
c'est ça en fait qui voilà les hommes
qui étaient détenteurs de tous les
pouvoirs politiques religieux enfin tous
les pouvoirs et donc voilà cette
réécriture féministe
comment dire
c'est très original je trouve de
chercher dans cette époque quelqu'un qui
se révolte contre le pour une femme qui
serait votre contrôle pouvoir oui bien
sûr et puis les chevaliers la table
ronde en prennent pour leur grade aussi
parce qu'on connaît évidemment
Perceval Perceval qui est dans le roman
graphique est particul
idiot alors on a toujours pardon
ce feuilleton Kaamelott oui je sais pas
si vous l'avez regardez oui en effet
percevoir
et là aussi oui donc ça doit être vrai
je pense oui oui je pense donc déjà la
façon dont il a géré un petit peu la
quête du Graal
c'est dans l'aide dans la matière
médiévale il est déjà assez
idiot
le fameux
là il est plutôt bon voilà avant d'être
un chevalier et c'est plutôt un amoureux
niais voilà donc bon
cheval
il est représenté avec des traits en
Fantin enfin bon des voilà et puis
Guenièvre aussi Guenièvre qui est dans
la matière médiévale bon et un peu
laissé pour compte
c'est la femme d'Arthur
avant la reine la reine et la femme
d'Arthur et donc là dans le roman
graphique elle troque la broderie contre
les armes donc c'est une agriculture
assez assez jubilatoire en fait je
dirais et réjouissante à lire qu'on soit
adepte du récit de la table ronde ou pas
et alors on le voit un petit peu mais
c'est vrai que c'est formidablement
illustré
le style des dessins je trouve est très
réussi j'aime beaucoup en fait il y a
des il y a des des tonalités des
couleurs très intéressantes qui varient
beaucoup en fonction des chapitres les
chapitres d'ailleurs on leur propre
planche comme enluminé de façon moderne
et moi ça m'a fait penser évidemment au
manuscrit d'époque du Moyen-Âge qui sont
tout enluminés et là ce serait une forme
un peu voilà on va dire moderne de ces
manuscrits là et des enluminures avec
peut-être la véritable histoire
du récit arturien ce récit qui a été
construit et fantasmé depuis des siècles
par des hommes en fait vous disiez que
ça vous avez fait beaucoup rire aussi il
y a de l'humour quoi en fait je dirais
que c'est surtout c'est surtout la
satire en fait c'est voilà comment
pas la vision de de ce monde parle par
les yeux d'une femme et d'une femme qui
se révolte contre
les auteurs détournent complètement les
codes chevaleresque et du coup c'est
très jubilatoire alors
de Simon quand Sarah et de Stéphane Ford
c'est ça
et c'est aux éditions Delcourt la
collection MIRAGE très bien parfait
voilà montrez-le bien on le voit on le
voit aussi à l'image Caroline Charden on
continue avec vous vous êtes d'accord
alors
sans rivage d'Hélène Gaudi publié en
2019 aux éditions Actes Sud voilà c'est
plus un récit
[Musique]
c'est ça dépend de quel point de vue
est-ce que c'est un
un récit de voyage est-ce que c'est un
roman archéologique ça dépend le point
de vue que l'on prend juste pour dire
rapidement il s'agit d'une enquête tout
simplement dont le point de départ c'est
voilà l'autrice elle s'intéresse à une
expédition qui a mal tourné on est dans
les années 30 c'est ça alors justement
c'est en fait c'est à la suite de d'une
importante fonte des glaces à l'été
justement 1930 que l'on découvre trois
corps de trois explorateurs suédois qui
sont portés quand même disparus depuis
1897 donc ça fait depuis un bon bout de
temps le nom de ces trois explorateurs
suédois sont Salomon à August Andries
nous franckle et Neels stringberg et
c'est trois explorateurs en fait avaient
un but un objectif c'était d'atteindre
le pôle Nord en ballon
et nous dès le début lecteur on est on
sait que cette expédition a mal tournée
qu'ils sont morts avec eux ils ne sont
pas devenus des héros nationaux c'est
aussi qu'il ne reste pas grand chose de
mais suffisamment pour créer une
histoire une enquête il reste des
pellicules encore encore assez intactes
pour être développé
par les conditions et le journal de bord
alors des fragments du journal de bord
d'André donc l'un des trois explorateurs
et ces deux éléments là donc les
pellicules et le journal constituent les
deux éléments qui sont le point de
départ de cette enquête et donc c'est ça
que j'ai mis dans ce livre c'est que au
début on sait dès le début ce qui va se
passer donc en fait Hélène Gaudy elle
mène toute une enquête pour en fait
s'imaginer comment ils en sont arrivés à
Alain
j'aime ce mélange d'archives de faits
historique et en même temps d'oeuvre
d'art pour essayer de retracer par
l'imagination et le pouvoir de
l'imagination voilà de savoir ce qu'ils
ont vécu ressenti et c'est un livre
extrêmement rythmique parce qu'il y a
des va-et-vient
c'est écriture elle est très très belle
elle met en évidence voilà les doutes
que l'enquitrice peut avoir
l'incertitude il y a comme une comme une
fille il y avait une esthétique de
l'errance avec le blanc du pôle nord de
la banquise et cette écriture du doute
de l'errance invite aussi le lecteur et
la lectrice à l'errance à réfléchir
parce que si les questions de cette
disparition des trois explorateurs en
fait en réalité il y a une double
disparition et c'est ce que j'aime dans
ce livre c'est que plus on tourne les
pages plus on découvre cette deuxième
disparition dont je vais pas dire
mais c'est ce que j'ai aimé et c'est ce
qui constitue la toile de fond et une de
motivation de d'Hélène Gody d'avoir
écrit ce livre
on sait qui sait une c'est une autrice
c'est un écrivaine oui elle est
écrivaine elle est née en 1979 voilà
et sécher
tout à fait
la disparition d'ailleurs accidentelle
du fondateur
donc ça s'appelle au monde sans rivage
et ce que j'ai aimé
avec le passé le présent permet en fait
de repenser de d'inviter le lecteur à
reconstruire enfin voilà à repenser en
fait l'histoire avec un grand H avec
cette histoire avec un petit h et
notamment l'imbrication des deux
histoires et nous notamment ben voilà
dans ce qui est des explorations des
grands voyages comment les femmes ont
été évincées c'est une critique
implicite de la coopération mais oui
bien sûr c'est une critique vraiment
forte implicite mais forte des
conditions des femmes à cette époque qui
en fait qui était privé du mouvement de
l'action de prendre part aux grands au
grand fait aux grandes actions aux
découvertes donc
prenez pas ces découvertes là ou enfin
voilà
cette idée que la femme reste dans son
foyer et que l'homme pouvait partir en
gros
Caroline des exploratrices
tout à l'heure c'est le même phénomène
exactement et c'est pour ça aussi parce
que oui il y a cette idée que la femme
doit se rester au foyer en gros
et surtout pas surtout pas loin non non
c'est sûr
des explorateurs Anna Charlier elle est
l'autrice passe beaucoup de temps à
faire dépeindre son portrait etc et
voilà à montrer que la femme est un
aimant considéré comme une mineure
ça donne très envie en tout cas de lire
on passe si je peux dire on passe miroir
avec vous clients donc
la passe-miroir c'est un système
ça dépend des régions je pense oui donc
oui il a passé miroir c'est une saga de
4 livres ce sont des livres de fantasy
qui se passent dans un univers où la ou
la Terre a été fracturée en différentes
îles flottantes appelées des arches ce
phénomène s'appelle la déchirure apprend
très très rapidement et ensuite donc
l'histoire d'Ophélie une conservatrice
de musique qui a le pouvoir de qui a des
pouvoirs surnaturels elle peut à la fois
le dire les objets le passé des objets
exactement et elle peut aussi traverser
les miroirs donc se déplacer d'où le nom
d'où le nom de la saga évidemment
un petit peu mais c'est très différent
et voilà donc c'est une saga de fantasy
qui nous permet de plonger vraiment dans
un univers tôt à la fois différent mais
qui a quand même des similitudes avec
notre monde et qui a beaucoup de
références c'est pas vraiment précisé ce
n'est pas précisément en effet disons
que le temps est un petit peu c'est il y
a des arches sont très très modernes
comme d'autres sont très très
anciennes on va dire donc
un petit peu flou mais justement c'est
ce qui rend la chose encore plus
intéressante pour moi et voilà donc
c'est un livre qui a été écrit par une
femme et qui enfin ce sont des livres
qui ont été écrits par une femme et qui
mettent en scène donc un personnage
féminin
ce que j'ai beaucoup aimé avec avec
cette saga c'est que tout le long
on suit le personnage mais en même temps
la voix évoluée et le fait d'être dans
son
la perspective si je dis pas de bêtises
vraiment centré sur elle donc on a
vraiment pensé à elle et on voit
vraiment comment son personnage évolue
du premier livre au dernier ce qui est
particulièrement intéressant
ça a toujours existé les séries mais
c'est vrai que non le mode des séries
télévisé est-ce que ça influe sur la
littérature à votre avis c'est une
possibilité après c'est comme c'est une
saga qui se
dont le public cible et la jeunesse
c'est vrai que dans le dans la
littérature jeunesse on retrouve
beaucoup plus de beaucoup plus de séries
plutôt que plutôt que de
one shot on va dire oui voilà donc
mais je pense que c'est une possibilité
en effet même enfin personnellement
après moi ça m'est dans mon écriture
c'est vrai que j'ai tendance à avoir
plus de
à imaginer mes univers plus en série
plutôt qu'en écrivez
tous un peu vu que c'est un peu aussi
merci beaucoup donc le passe-miroir de
Christelle Davos vous vouliez ajouter
quelque chose
[Musique]
dans le sens où c'est paru
logique en effet et c'est en soi c'est
vraiment une lecture très très
intéressante qui est on sent vraiment
que l'univers est travaillé les
personnages sont travaillés et le style
aussi est très très travaillé et ce qui
est assez
ce qui renouvelle un petit peu on va
dire le la littérature jeunesse l'auteur
est française elle est française elle a
été publiée chez Gallimard Jeunesse et
le ce livre là est d'ailleurs le premier
lauréat du prix du prix du premier roman
de Gallimard RTL et Télérama ou
justement le but est de d'avoir des
auteurs qui n'ont jamais enfin des
écrivains des écrivains qui n'ont jamais
publié de romans dans dans la jeunesse
et qui pour pouvoir publier leurs
premières voilà bravo merci
à vous donner tous envie c'est vachement
bien
et ben maintenant
Coralie Fanny
une saga donc c'est une trilogie mais je
viens seulement vous donner envie de la
lire du coup moi ça se base aussi sur
sur une héroïne oui alors
ça se voit pas mal dans son écriture
elle a une formation militaire et donc
étonnamment on trouve plein de scènes de
batailles et que j'ai trouvé plutôt
compréhensible par rapport à d'autres
romans que j'ai pu lire ça donne une
vraie dimension orange mais le principal
c'est pas la bataille c'est une jeune
fille qui s'appelle voilà c'est ça c'est
toujours une question de mariage
elle s'appelle sage Fowler et en fait
c'est une roturière qui est élevée par
son oncle et c'est son oncle qui va la
présenter à une mariée et donc les
mariuses ont un rôle politique
extrêmement
prégnant et c'est elle qui décide de
nouer les alliances entre certaines
familles et on pourrait penser que c'est
simplement politique mais en fait il y a
une
comme on dit on va appeler ça
par rapport au caractère donc elle
essaye quand même d'assortir c'est un
peu plus humain et en fait on se
retrouve en devant elle elle va perdre
complètement ses moyens et finalement au
lieu d'être marié c'est elle qui va
apprendre le travail de Mario et donc
elle va se mettre à espionner les
candidats du concordium du coup le plus
grand rassemblement de jeunes gens à
marier avec les plus fortes alliances
politiques et du coup voilà elle se
retrouve à les espionner et elle se rend
compte au final que il y a une menace
extérieure
voilà qui
qui qui pointe le bout de son nez et en
fait elle va se trouver à un collègue
espion et ils vont
énormément et pas mal de retournements
aussi des
mélange entre Game of Thrones et Mario
premier regard
en effet
vous avez vous avez lu chacun les les
livres dont Paul les autres
[Musique]
c'est un livre que vous qui vous tient
quoi
je l'ai relu exprès pour aujourd'hui
j'ai eu du mal à m'arrêter là
c'est pas forcément
alors la maison d'édition publie
énormément de séries que je lis voilà
c'est une maison d'édition que je
suivais j'ai eu l'humaine d'accord et
donc j'ai lu le résumé j'ai lu j'ai
acheté le livre et voilà j'ai acheté les
deux suivants
je rappelle peut-être les les livres
dont on a parlé donc il y avait Morgane
de Simon conservat et Stéphane fer un
monde sur rivage
d'Hélène Gaudi le passe-miroir de
crécelle Dabo ou la bosse
et la couleur du mensonge de Bitty qui
est une Américaine
justement est-ce que depuis que vous
avez ces livres est-ce que le dernier
livre que vous avez lu et qui vous a plu
actuellement je suis en train de lire
pareil aux éditions Actes Sud les
fantômes de la nuit c'est écrit par
Laurent Tillon qui est un ingénieur
forestier et écrivain ingénieur
forestier de la forêt de Rambouillet
d'accord
spécialise des chauves-souris et c'est
très intéressant je m'intéresse beaucoup
bah voilà à la question
climatiques au vivant qui nous entoure
et c'est un livre absolument fabuleux et
je précise
plutôt plongée dans mes lectures de
recherche pour moi et puis l'écriture
aussi
sur les métamorphoses politiques de la
violence par des voix féminines donc des
réécritures de mythes contemporaines en
poésie en théâtre et en roman
et donc ça c'est passionnant et c'est
c'est sur la violence donc c'est c'est
un sujet quand même assez
oui mais voilà
personnellement actuellement je suis
dans plein lecture de la série de manga
One Piece d'accord voilà et François
c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire dessus
vous êtes dedans donc oui voilà
exactement il me reste beaucoup de temps
du coup bah pour mémoire aussi parce que
il y a des études aussi écoutez merci
infiniment à tous les cas et puis alors
on se retrouve comme vous voulez on va
faire d'ailleurs une autre émission avec
d'autres étudiants non l'idée vous serez
là hein
un peu un peu lourd mais très très fort
dont la Shoah notamment merci merci
encore à tous les quatre
[Musique]